ha sido el heredero al trono durante la
mayor parte de su vida el príncipe
carlos se convirtió el primero en la
línea de sucesión con sólo tres años fue
el comienzo de una vida de preparación
para su papel como futuro rey basada en
gran parte a la sombra de su madre tras
una educación privada carlos se
convirtió en el primer heredero al trono
en obtener una licenciatura trans
graduarse en cambridge en 1970 a los 20
años fue investido como el vigésimo
primer príncipe de gales el título que
se otorga a los herederos masculinos del
trono británico
ruth cambio lee yo carlos príncipe de
gales me convierto en su señor de la
vida y de la fe
carlos sirvió entonces en la real fuerza
aérea y en la marina real
en 1981 se anunció el compromiso del
príncipe de gales y lady diana spencer
de 19 años lo que llevó a la pareja a un
frenesí mediático
simplemente encantado y feliz estoy
asombrado de que haya sido tan valiente
como para aceptarme
y supongo que enamorada claro
lo que sea que signifique estar
enamorado
unos meses después su boda fue vista por
750 millones de espectadores en todo el
mundo marcando un punto álgido de
popularidad para la familia real los
príncipes de gales tuvieron dos hijos el
príncipe guillermo segundo en la línea
de sucesión al trono y el príncipe harry
su matrimonio se volvió cada vez más
tenso en medio de años de intenso
escrutinio y de rumores de infidelidad
por ambas partes que salpicaron las
portadas en escena bahiense los seis del
palacio de buckingham que con pesar el
principio la princesa de gales han
decidido separarse en 1993 el romance de
carlos con su antigua amiga y ex novia
camila parker bowles se hizo público
cuando se filtró la transcripción de una
llamada telefónica íntima en 1989 entre
ambos
el príncipe admitió un adulterio en un
documental en 1997 un año después de
finalizar su divorcio diana una figura
muy querida por el público británico y
más allá murió en un accidente de coche
en parís
al principio carlos y la reina parecía
no estar a la altura del dolor nacional
la popularidad de la familia real cayó
en picado
dos años más tarde carlos y camila
hicieron su primera aparición como
pareja la opinión pública de la pareja
era mixta se casaron en 2005 desatando
años de feroz debate sobre sí camila
sería algún día reina especulaciones que
sólo terminaron cuando la reina isabel
manifestó su deseo de que camila fuera
reina consorte cuando carlos se
convirtiera en rey implicado en más de
cuatrocientas organizaciones benéficas
el príncipe de gales es conocido por su
labor filantrópica que en ocasiones ha
estado en el punto de mira por sus
polémicas relaciones nos hemos reunido
como padre e hijo para apreciar nuestra
voz al creciente esfuerzo mundial en la
lucha contra el comercio ilegal de
especies silvestres también es uno de
los miembros más francos de la familia
real y con frecuencia expresa su opinión
en ámbitos como la arquitectura el
cambio climático y el medio ambiente con
el paso de los años fue asumiendo más
funciones a medida que la casa real se
preparaba para la transición y la salud
de la reina empeoraba la más notable fue
leer el discurso de la reina en su
nombre para abrir el parlamento por
primera vez en 2022 el año que celebró
sus 70 años en el trono
señores y miembros de la cámara de los
comunes
la prioridad de gobierno para su
majestad es hacer crecer y fortalecer la
economía para la mayoría del público
británico la reina isabel es la única
monarca que han conocido y ha seguido
siendo muy popular a lo largo de sus
décadas en el trono el reinado de carlos
marcará el comienzo de una era para una
familia real cuya reputación se ha visto
mermada por los escándalos mientras que
las encuestas han indicado una creciente
desafección con la monarquía entre los
jóvenes